to Senate committees want more
information about that meeting Senate
Intelligence vice-chairman Mark Warner
says they've requested documents from
Donald Trump jr. and Jared Kushner who
also met with the Russian lawyer he
expects both to testify before Congress
Senate Judiciary Chairman Chuck Grassley
also says he wants Trump jr. to testify
the cover of The New Yorker magazines
upcoming issue shows the president
kicking his son-in-law and pulling his
oldest son by the ear major Garrett is
at the White House and if history is any
indication major this issue not likely
to sit well with this president that's
true that's correct
good morning Russian revelations follow
President Trump to Paris they'll be
waiting for him upon his return now is
the president flew to France aboard Air
Force One quite obviously he spoke to
reporters a conversation originally
off-the-record then placed on the record
by the president and in that
conversation he defended his son Don jr.
calling him quote a good kid a good boy
and as well he defended his lengthy
meeting with Russian President Vladimir
Putin where the president raised but
didn't really press the issue of Russian
election meddling pluton denied hacking
the election twice and after that the
president said he dropped the issue
telling reporters quote what do you do
end up in a fistfight with somebody okay
the president said he will at the right
time invite Putin to the White House
it's just too hot politically to do that
at the moment president also expressed
some sympathy with Chinese President Xi
Jinping and US and Chinese efforts to
deter North Korea's pursuit of nuclear
weapons saying China must look out for
its own interest and she is aware of
that now the president's son-in-law
reference just a moment ago that New
Yorker covered Jared Kushner also under
renewed scrutiny CBS News has learned
that three times Kushner had to amend
his security clearance request here at
the White House the first one didn't
include any mention of foreign national
meetings the second one did the third
one only included a meeting of that or
mentioned rather of that now-infamous
meeting with the Russian lawyer in June
of 2016
Norah all right major thank you